foreign
is in Spokane Washington hey Brandon
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey thanks for having me sure what's up
um so me and the wife we're I'm 23 right
now
um we just got finished up with baby
step three so we got our six-month
emergency fund we don't have any kids or
anything We're just trying to figure out
where do we go from here do we start
saving for a house I know we are kind of
enjoying some money right now
um I'm just curious if we stay gazelle
intense and gave up all we can for a
down payment or
what do we do is that your next goal to
buy a house
um I believe so we're hoping yeah we
hope to have a kiddo here sometime in
the future and
just trying to
I don't know want to prepare ourselves
for the future so well that's great well
we would call that baby step 3B where
you save up your down payment for your
house we don't want you to stay there
forever but I mean if that is a goal and
you're wanting to bring the baby home
into a house that you own
um then yeah go ahead and start saving
in that and then of course after that
you know your baby steps four through
six where you're going to start saving
for retirement your kids college fund
and then paying off that house
I have a feeling you already knew that
kind of did yeah I
um like after baby step three would be
baby step four you knew that
yes
yeah
um we're just
you know enjoying a little bit of the
money and that's why she said that so
you're spending everything now
not quite worth it again we got eighteen
thousand dollars put away into our uh
our six-month emergency fund that's your
emergency fund and now if you want a
house you're gonna have to quit enjoying
so much
yeah you know new goal new goal be
intentional uh don't just kind of wander
off into stupid land again you just you
just visited there and um you don't want
to live there that's why you walked your
way out don't go back so stay very
intentional very focused
keep on the game plan yes you can enjoy
your money a little bit we don't have to
go down to beans and rice rice and beans
you're past that now but you do need to
be intentional and I have no money past
my emergency fund three years from now
because I've been enjoying my money is
not a plan